mich hat heute etwas sehr gefreut mich
hat gefreut ist youtube heute verloren
hat gegen die schauspieler die künstler
von alles auf den tisch und zwar youtube
videos gelöscht von der aktion alles auf
den tisch ziehen die aktion nicht sagt
es gab erst alles dicht machen wo
künstler sich gegen die krone maßnahmen
aufgelehnt haben dann gab es die aktion
alles auf den tisch wo künstler
interviews geführt haben es gab zum
beispiel interview volker bruch ein
medienwissenschaftler interviewt hat und
einfach mal andere sichtweisen ja
vielleicht auch einfach erlaubt hat bei
dass in der medienlandschaft wichtig
youtube hat dann einige der clips
gelöscht gehabt weil sie corona kritisch
sein weil sie hohe erläutern wird ich
bin damals die ganze mediathek
durchgegangen von alles auf den tisch
und das war kein grüner läuft es war
einfach eine andere sich der fakten des
wahren diskussion heute hat dann auch
youtube verloren das kölner landgericht
hatte in kreativen recht gegeben und
youtube hätte die videos nicht löschen
sollen das hat nicht gefreut weil es
trauen sich nur noch unter 50 prozent
der deutschen also weniger als 50
prozent der deutschen ihre politische
meinung zu sagen und ich glaube es ist
wichtig dass so aktion erlaubt sind und
dementsprechend halt nicht dass heute
gefreut und damit möchte ich die runde
eröffnet man ist es überhaupt gar kein
problem mit meinung zu haben eine
meinung steht jedem zu und na klar ist
nicht jeder kritiker ein leugner auf der
anderen seite ist das problem dass der
der die meidung hat nicht derjenige sein
muss der die meinung vielleicht falsch
umsetzt und die konsequenzen davon
tragen muss wenn er sie falsch umgesetzt
hat und das sehe ich durchaus so ein
bisschen problematisch weil die
konsequenzen für das was schief gehen
kann tragen ganze familien trägt
eventuell ein einzelnes leben und trägen
dran wieder die die sowieso die ganze
zeit diese pandemie getragen haben
nämlich die leute in den kliniken und
das finde ich so ein bisschen schwierig
an gibt es verschiedene meinungen die
meinung bezahlt man teuer eventuellen
naja wir sehen ja meinung ist ja auch
sehr unterschiedlich also wenn wir uns
auf das kaprizieren was beispielsweise
das robert-koch-institut ja vermeldet
hat und das robert koch-institut geht ja
immer als so eine instanz eigentlich in
dieser pandemie da müssen wir auch
feststellen offenbar ist bei den zahlen
wenn es um die geimpften beispielsweise
geht auch nicht alles richtig da gibt es
offenbar mehr die schon doppelt gm sind
als offiziell ausgewiesen wird
was gut ist auf jeden fall was sie sagen
will ist also die zahlen des robert koch
instituts in frage zu stellen wenn man
sagt vielleicht ist doch nicht alles
ganz richtig das kam ja schon
gotteslästerung quasi gleich wie stellt
aber offenbar fest die zahlen sind in
der tat nicht richtig und deswegen ist
es ganz ganz schwer glaube ich zu sagen
die eine meinung ist richtig und die
andere meinung ist falsch weil es so
viele fakten gibt
sich zum teil gar nicht richtig
nachvollziehen lassen und das ist mit
meinung natürlich auch wie ich frage
mich viel macht darf youtube google
facebook twitter und andere über uns und
unsere politische diskurse haben dann
hier geht es darum als amerikanischer
unternehmer entscheidet was da online
bleibt und wer nicht und ich kenne diese
videos nicht ich will kein kleiner
diesem video bewerten denn da geht mal
kurz zur einschätzung ist war zum
beispiel eins der videos war zum
beispiel mit dem leipziger mathematik
professor stefan lukas und dem
neurobiologen gerald hüther als weiß
auch nicht irgendwie wie man sich das
vorstellt ich hab die videos alle auf
der seite angeschaut das war jetzt nicht
wirklich
um diese macht das amerikanische
unternehmer oder andere unternehmer
haben aber das was man sagen darf und
was nicht und dass sie die macht haben
auch sachen zu löschen und da übrigens
sie tun das komplett selektiv das heißt
bei anderen sachen sind sie auf einmal
sehr tolerant wenn es um islamismus geht
wenn es um in antisemitismus geht und
diese aufgabe gehört hier in deutschland
das müssen deutsche gerichte entscheiden
und gut dass es so diese entscheidung
getroffen hat und nicht irgendwelche
leute die bei youtube oder bei google
arbeiten ja absolut aber es immer bei
dieser debatte die wir in deutschland
auch hatten wer entscheidet eigentlich
was gelöscht werden sollen was mich und
wer ist demokratisch legitimiert sie
sprechen das recht an entscheidet dass
so ein konzern der über den atlantik
sitzt und entscheidet hier welche
inhalte zu sehen bekommen wer
entscheidet in deutschland ist die große
frage ich finde auch dass das urteil
heute wichtig war und zwar in der frage
dass wir die meinungspluralität haben in
diesem land viele leute vermissen dass
in diesen tagen die haben das gefühl
ihre meinung wenn sie nicht mainstream
ist sie schon auf einer seite abgestellt
die sie weg sie dürfen ihre meinung
nicht mehr sagen und das ist gefährlich
für unsere demokratie wir brauchen die
vielfalt an meinungen
sie falsch sind muss es jemand aufklären
dafür gibt es genügend medien auch um
das klar zu machen und sagen dass es
eine fixe der muss richtig gestellt
werden aber das bedarf diesen austausch
und das kann auch eine falsche meinung
seien auch die ist notwendig damit man
eine debatte führen können ist
interessant zu sehen mit welchem furor
auch bei alles dicht machen also bei der
ersten aktion der künstler reagiert
wurde wie künstler und fern auch unter
jahr gesetzt wurden wie es sogar
jemanden aus dem rundfunkrat des wdr gab
ein ehemaliger spd minister der sogar
dann das tatort verbot für jan josef
liefers nicht nur als forderte also
moderator andi das gefordert haben
instagram ein chor ist wirklich
verschiedenste variable also da da ist
doch das thema was sie auch gerade
ansprechender mohring das thema
meinungsfreiheit mittlerweile einem
korridor ich glaube niemand bestreitet
dass corona eine gefährliche krankheit
ist ein gefährliches virus ist ein
extrem gefährliches virus ist aber die
frage ist ja auch was ist zulässig und
wenn man auch heute liest eine neue
studie die besagt zum beispiel dass in
der korona pandemie die depressionen
essstörungen bei menschen dramatisch
zugenommen haben dann sehen wir ja dass
das verhalten beispielsweise ein ganzes
land über wochen in ein lokal zu
schicken quasi als alternativlos
offenbar doch doch viele andere
folgewirkung hatte und die frage hätte
man nicht alternativen mehr diskutieren
müssen um jetzt andere krankheiten eben
nicht zu haben die wir glaube ich sage
ich wir werden lange damit mit den
folgen zu kämpfen haben
sozialpsychologisch der sozialraum ist
kaputt gemacht worden wenn der
universität in der schule das wo wir uns
austauschen oder scannen im sportverein
all das konnte nicht stattfinden und das
hat viele menschen zu sagen brücher
hinterlassen in ihrem leben und das
wären wir noch langfristig spüren der
werden neue krankheitskosten entstehen
die heute noch gar nicht sehen die
sachen in folge der pandemie auf uns
hereinbrechen werden als gesellschaft
das wird uns noch mächtig herausfordern
absolut das habe ich auch letzte woche
auch hier die motiviert ich nenne das
den long korrekt aber den anderen longo
wird also dieses soziale folgen von der
lock down aber ich habe damals schon in
der erste und zweite welle auch meine
stimme erhoben und habe das immer wieder
geschrieben und ich würde alles corona
leugner betitelt ich bin nicht mal aus
dem haus raus gegangen und maske ich
habe mich als erste impfen lassen alles
ist möglich ist ich erkenne die gefahren
von corona aber es muss eine gesunde
diskurs in diesem land glücklich sein
dass man sagt ist es nie
monothematisch und es gibt über demo
logische folge es gibt aber
psychologische und soziologische folgen
die man komplett unterdrückt hat und
nicht darüber reden wollte und darüber
müssen wir jetzt uns gedanken machen wie
wir zukünftig eine bessere diskussion
indem wir nach schönem einen rein weil
ich meine dem gesichtsausdruck ablesen
zu können es werden nicht alle unsere
thesen auf gegenliebe stoßen das ist
glaube ich völlig normal erst mal glaube
ich dass der satz ich glaube niemand
leugnet corona der haut nicht ganz hin
dass leugnen noch leute coruna und dann
ist doch der unterschied zwischen einem
demokratischen diskurs den kann jeder
von mir aus jeder zeit haben über von
von allen richtungen her wenn er nicht
zu diesen folgen führt dass diejenigen
die kritik machen zusammen in einen topf
geworfen werden mit diejenigen die es
lohnen denn denn es gibt ja ganz oft in
debatten halt nur noch das eine oder das
andere
diese debatten befeuerung macht eben
keinen diskurs sondern es macht einfach
nur zwei fronten ein bisschen schärfer
das verschafft mir ab und gab es gab
diese frage die glauben york times
nachgegangen ist wann endet eigentlich
eine pandemie und die frage und in die
antwort war auch im vergangenheit sie
wissen es wahrscheinlich viel besser
wenn die menschen die angst davon
verlieren oder davor an verlieren und
wir verlieren gerade die angst und das
ist gut so wir sind geimpft wir haben
einen schritt in richtung normalität
gemacht und ich bitte sogar dafür dass
die leute jetzt mehr in sozialen
kontakten geht mehr in witten sich
trauen auch auf veranstaltungen zu gehen
miteinander im gespräch zu gehen das ist
absolut normal es ist natürlich auch
eine gewisse
ignorieren von den krankheiten und die
gefahren das machen wir übrigens jeden
tag mit unglaublich viele risikofaktoren
die wir eigentlich tagtäglich
was uns passieren konnte das ist völlig
in ordnung und wir mussten raus aus
dieser eindimensionaler betracht punkte
bekommt der akw spiele hat ja vergangene
woche bereits schon eine neue ebene
eingezogen in dem wir haben ja die
grippe quasi auf eine auf eine ebene
schon mit corona gestellt hat und da
haben sie glaube ich vollkommen recht
herr mansour in dieser logik müssten wir
eigentlich ab oktober jetzt alle wieder
zu hause bleiben und in den grippe
locker und gehen denn da drückt jetzt
die nächste krankheit und wir wissen wie
viele das ist mehrere 10.000 grippetote
pro jahr gibt also die nächste krankheit
ein dann ein leben offenbar still zu
legen ist glaube ich ein vollkommen
richtig ab und zu sagen wir müssen ab
einem gewissen punkt aber in gewissen
grad auch sagen so wie in dänemark jetzt
ist diese pandemie vorbei es gibt
genügend geimpfte und natürlich gibt es
menschen die sich nicht empfehlen können
das ist tragisch die brauchen anderen
schutz zu marvel haben wir richtig die
die folgekosten nenne ich jetzt einfach
mal einer dauerhaften pandemie lockdown
gehabe auf psychologische haben ja
psychischer aber auch ökonomische seite
sind extrem und die muss man irgendwie
immer miteinander in balance bringen
[Musik]